[Musique]
Salut les Terriens Salut les Terriens je
suis très heureux de me retrouver notre
invité principal ce soir c'est bien
Arditi
j'ai arrêté
Bonsoir
combien ça fait 5 ans que vous n'êtes
pas venu dans une de mes émissions 5 ans
qu'on se voit un coup de fil par SMS
rien
en fait depuis que je fais une émission
sans bimbo de la téléréalité sans stars
du X vous venez plus non non parce que
c'est ça qui me l'a maintenant
franchement et voilà
je me venge de tous les jours merci
de nous accueillir de nouveau invité
pour discuter avec nous deux ce qu'on
fait de l'actualité de la semaine
Thierry Mariani
secrétaire d'État aux transports
enfin ministre ils ont rêvé la dernière
fois qu'il est venu ici il était pas
encore ne me reprocher à Sarkozy de pas
l'avoir nommé ministre d'avoir pris pour
un con en même temps ça lui fait un
point commun avec les autres français
toujours en paix de nous accueillerons
svp mail
président du site d'information Mediator
qui publie le président de trop chez Don
Quichotte
[Applaudissements]
alors pierre Bonsoir 5 ans qu'on s'est
pas vu tu as pas changé qu'est-ce que tu
viens je suis marié j'ai toujours les
mêmes enfants ils ont un peu grande
en fait on s'est vu samedi au théâtre
Montparnasse dans votre l'âge après la
représentation d'une pièce de Florian
Zeller qui s'appelle la vérité et je
vous ai dit tu as jamais été meilleur
je sais pas si j'ai passé une soirée de
rêve tu es extraordinaire je dis à tout
le monde aller voir cette pièce c'est
difficile mais c'est bourré depuis le
mois de janvier mais si vous pouvez y
aller c'est rare que je fasse des
compliments mais là franchement
[Applaudissements]
alors on va voir à quoi ça ressemble
[Musique]
pourquoi on fait plus l'amour
mon amour
non
on pourrait partir ensemble
[Musique]
un jour
je voulais te parler
j'ai l'impression qu'elle me trompe
tu le vois pas
mets
c'est
dur
et tellement plus simple si tu veux
la vérité une comédie de Florian Zeller
mise en scène par Patrice Kerbrat avec
vous Fanny Cottençon Christiane Millet
et Patrice Kerbrat c'est une qu'est-ce
que j'ai l'air a écrit pour vous pouvez
oui il a ça ça m'a fait très plaisir que
j'avais beaucoup de numération pour ce
jeune il est très jeune il a 30 ans et
la première pièce il l'a envoyé et je
lui ai répondu 1h30 après qui vit la
question à part moi et
une nuit entière ensemble vous organiser
un gros mensonge
[Applaudissements]
la vérité c'est que j'ai passé quand
même une super soirée et
maintenant
vous êtes né le 1er décembre 44
les enfants de la différence
et il a le droit de peindre sur le
tableau
et
exemple
on peut on peut on peut
quand même
elle qui allait vomir en scène entre
deux chansons de Brel j'ai une couille
avec une guitare
en scène curieusement en
même temps
Lyon 1965 dans l'opéra du monde
Audiberti là là c'est parti et c'est
comme ça que le monde enfin s'illumine
et voilà et le monde découvre Pierre
Arditi et depuis c'est vrai
Salut Vincent alors
au cinéma ça sera un peu moins énorme
oui oui oui oui
22 ans vous êtes engagé à 14h, à 16h
je sors du bureau il me dit oui donc je
sors fou de joie et de
tout le temps
et
encore aujourd'hui je n'ai pas encore eu
le rôle de ma vie non je peux pas dire
ça ce que je peux dire ce que
je pense que je fais
[Musique]
quelque chose
mais c'est comme ça
une raison d'être
c'est que c'est que c'est comme ça la
vie l'as décidé et c'est pas grave on
peut pas être amoureux de toujours d'une
femme qui a un moment donné vous regarde
de temps en temps avec condescendance et
puis qui ensuite va regarder ailleurs
c'est comme ça bah bon voilà quand elle
me fais signe je suis là me fais pas
signe je vais vers celle qui m'aime
bourgeois il voulait jouer un [ __ ] je
fais
pas
comme ça
le rôle était absolument à verser c'est
magnifique et alors après 25 ans de vie
commune vous êtes marié il y a 1 ans en
faire un petit bilan au niveau fidélité
ça va super
j'ai jamais été aussi mal de ma vie et
je n'ai plus aucune raison
que nous sommes tous les avantages et
les inconvénients du
rendez-vous à faire ensemble
on se retrouve après la pub avec Thierry
Mariani
l'actualité
[Musique]
un roman sur le terrarium nous sommes
toujours en compagnie de Pierre Arditi
et nous accueillons avec elle
Thierry Mariani Bonsoir
alors Thierry Mariani il y a à peine en
vous déclarer Sarkozy m'avais promis un
secrétariat d'État résultats c'est rond
qui lui a craché à la gueule qui devient
ministre Sarkozy plus tu crache à la
gueule plus il t'aime vous avez raison
vous aviez raison vous l'avez cracher à
la gueule résultats vous êtes secrétaire
d'État
[Musique]
tu peux plus cracher à la gueule vous
soyez pas secrétaire d'État aux
transports vous serez à l'intérieur aux
Affaires étrangères peut-être
depuis 94 je crois que j'ai surtout été
un ami fidèle alors par moment on peut
avoir des moments d'énervement et
quelques déclaration que j'ai fait mais
faut pas oublier aussi peut-être 17 ou
18 années avant une déclaration
pas de bol à peine nommé il neige en
plein hiver en
1987 en France
les avions il fallait dépasser au
produit il y avait plus de produit il y
a pas école voilà je m'en souviens dans
l'avion et alors les transports comment
ça se passe
c'est plus
souvent
et qui permettent d'avoir encore
quelques
heures et c'est bon ça se passe bien
Nicolas Sarkozy
plusieurs rencontres où est les députés
de la droite Populaire lui prend par des
préoccupations sur certains sujets
notamment par exemple le projet de loi
sur les jury populaire plus présent
désormais dans les affaires judiciaires
c'est par exemple une idée qu'on partagé
qui aboutit
obtenir un truc Sarko à la gueule
[Applaudissements]
Bonsoir donc je suis si ce soir pour le
lancement de l'opération une moustache
pour la liberté de la presse
c'est absolument concernant
il y a des répliques de sa moustache qui
vont être vendu un peu partout au prix
de 2 € pour se tenir sans combat
ceci étant le site d'information
Mediapart dont vous êtes le fondateur
est le président a atteint l'équilibre
financier ça prouve finalement que
s'enfonçant fabricant d'armement sans
mettre des travaux publics on arrive pas
à ma paire de l'info dans ce pays c'est
pas comme au Figaro Figaro ils peuvent
pas trop causer des dessous de la guerre
en Libye parce que les rafales contre
Dassault ouais c'est le propriétaire qui
fait la guerre des deux côtés
nous avons révélé c'est assez douloureux
la lettre qui a envoyé le suicide et de
France Telecom en 2009 qui a l'air tu es
déjà et qui a l'air tel la DRH
d'être en trop bien sûr c'est c'est
Mediapart qui a révélé ça grâce à
Fresnes fixe quelqu'un nous l'a envoyé
dans le nucléaire on a eu aussi quelques
informations comme cela les bancs de
Bettencourt on peut les réécouter
tranquillement Les Contes du groupe
Bolloré les dessous de l'histoire de la
Caisse d'Épargne enfin bref on fait
notre travail de citoyens et puis de
l'autre côté on dit au lanceur d'alerte
qu'ils peuvent à l'ère du numérique
envoyer de manière crypter sécurisé des
documents qu'on publiera pas sans les
avoir coupé vérifier exploiter le vais
rencontrer Julian Assange oui on a fait
une pierre view même dans sa cuisine de
son manoir anglais assez drôle ah c'est
décalé c'est quelqu'un de très
intéressant c'est un quelqu'un qui a un
vrai combat pour la démocratie sans
frontières c'est pas un illuminé
quelqu'un qui veut vraiment cette idée
que il y a une stratégie du faible au
fort que quand on arrive à montrer que
le roi est nu et bien le roi il tombe et
c'est ce qui est arrivé pour Ben Ali et
Moubarak ça va aller telegram WikiLeaks
ont vu un effet redoutable alors vous
publiez aux éditions Don Quichotte le
président de trop sous-titré vertus de
lentilles sarkozysme et vis du
présidentialisme alors pour vous en
faites Sarkozy exacerbe le
présidentialisme français le
présidentialisme est au régime
présidentiel ce que l'intégrisme météo
religion
que ce système excessif ce président qui
n'a pas le sens des limites qui est
transgressif sans
contre-pouvoir sacré la courtisane riz
sacré toutes ces nomination vous dit en
fait ce présidentialisme et un héritage
du bonapartisme
césarisme dire que nous on a une
catastrophe c'est qu'on a coupé la tête
du roi mais on a un néanmoins mets la
monarchie dans la culture c'est
compliqué donc on a toujours cette idée
du Grand un le grand en présidentielle
et qui crée CC comment dire cette façon
de s'identifier à un seul qui est pour
moi le niveau le plus bas du débat
politique mais est-ce que problème tu ne
sais pas l'élection du président
République au suffrage universel le
président des États-Unis et néanmoins
quand il peut pas nous mais n'importe
comment il y a des auditions au congrès
des contrôles et
il
y
avait avant il n'y avait aucun
parce que Nicolas Sarkozy
je ne peuvent pas aller la justice et
ton travée dans regarder l'affaire
Bettencourt les nominations
l'audio-visuel public le Président il se
contente pas de nommer un mail qui a
travaillé au Figaro qui n'est pas un
révolter a raconté que le Président il
s'occupe des programmes
je suis passé après une de ces émissions
il a appelé Patrice Duhamel on était
quatre deux plutôt d'opposition de
plutôt de la majorité il a dit mais
pourquoi tu avais le quatrième il y a
pas besoin il était trop bon c'est un
compliment mais quand même c'est une
république bananière je dis ça parce que
ce qui m'autorise à parler comme ça vous
savez parce que la droite était bien
contente de mes révélation sous la
présidence de Mitterrand Sarkozy est pas
mécontent quand j'ai publié la cassette
Méry donc personne ne voulait qui
concerne et Jacques Chirac donc je ne
peux pas m'accuser d'être de particulier
ce que je voudrais c'est qu'on est
d'abord un président qui rassemble ce
pays la critique principal que je fais à
Nicolas c'est de mettre en guerre ce
pays contre lui-même c'est de stériliser
la politique est vraiment pour moi le
marqueur profond j'avais l'article 1er
du préambule de notre Constitution dit
que la France ne fais pas de distinction
entre ses citoyens selon l'origine selon
la race selon la religion c'était
quelque chose qui unifier la droite et
la gauche républicaine des gaullistes
aux communistes et bien ça ça a volé en
éclats avec Monsieur Sarkozy et ses amis
comme
il serait pas mieux d'avoir un président
sage
inaugurate heure de le chrysanthème
façon 4e République
quelque chose qui va être le miroir de
ce pays du football français
officiel depuis quelques mois a été
lancé l'opération blanchiment depuis les
gamin de 1213 ans trop de Black il y en
a trop il y a trop de black vous vous
rendez compte que ça veut dire c'était
des noms les enfants des banlieues
divers de la diversité française des
minorités visibles ils sont pas la tête
des médias ils sont pas la tête des
grands groupes industriels ils sont pas
la tête de la politique il avait le
sport et on dit pas sur la compétence
avec des phrases terrible ouais il faut
changer la logique du jeu ouais on
disait c'est les grands et les baleines
et les grands les baleines c'est les
Africains c'est les Noirs c'est les
blagues les blagues parce que il y a les
Antillais non il faut revenir à un jeu
plus intelligente des petits Rabelais et
c'est blanc
qui a été créé permet des choses comme
ça et le foot c'est le miroir de toute
la jeunesse française
et
il n'y a pas que le foot
te dire aussi c'est que moi je vais très
bien j'adore le foot c'était pas mais
enfin ils ont pas le le nouveau le
nouveau grade du monde dans lequel nous
vivons il va aller sortir de la merde et
la culture sélectionner
[Applaudissements]
les colis la pour la mettre des gosses
entre deux rangées de CRS à l'école je
suis
encore sur le livre donc il y a des
formules
avec Nicolas Sarkozy croyais avoir un
président en quelques jours à peine elle
a découvert un gagnant du loto
le problème c'est que le gagnant du loto
il a fait comme tous les gagnants du
Loto il a tout plaquer en 5 ans
je trouve quand même un peu dur avec
Nicolas Sarkozy il a qu'à me donner la
Légion d'honneur à Daniela Lumbroso
vous êtes jaloux
maintenant à ceux qui ont fait
l'actualité de la semaine avec l'édito
de Blacko et c'est Anna Cabana grand
reporter au point que nous retrouverons
sur ce plateau après le magnéto
[Musique]
Carla Bruni-Sarkozy est-elle enceinte la
nouvelle n'est pas confirmé mais elle
n'est pas non plus démenti
du coup à la rentrée le président
Sarkozy nous allons sera peut-être qu'il
est à nouveau papa est à nouveau
candidat
[Musique]
en tout cas ce ne serait pas la première
fois que Nicolas nous fait partager sa
vie privée de son fils Louis est en
photo dans Paris Match pour le sous le
bureau du ministre de l'intérieur de la
maison blanche à
la communication
en 2008
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand les élections fais mon arme
secrète avait déclaré Clément qui depuis
est devenu premier ministre d'ailleurs
lorsque ça qui est né en bon papa
moderne il a pris 14 jours de congé
paternité vous croyez que notre
président pourrais faire pareil parce
que pour faire élire pour raconter des
belles victoires fait le principe du
storytelling et le cliché du jeune papa
maladroit qui pouponne rien de tel pour
attendrir le cœur des ménagères un bébé
qui sourit exprime d'innocence
qu'elle bosse un vol pour 2012
d'ailleurs c'est comme ça de Mitterrand
se faire élire en 1988 il a juste coller
un bébé sur ses affiches de campagne
c'était l'édito de placo dans l'image de
Julien grappe
bonsoir.
J'ai vendu 200000 exemplaires d'un livre
consacré à Cécilia Sarkozy
amaigri que c'est le signe de l'effort
consenti pour pour devenir candidat et
là maintenant c'est Carla Bruni tu m'as
fait rire dans la séquence
vu que Carla Bruni et
d'entretien
pour
aimable
[Musique]
les histoires de grossesse donc on se
retrouve aujourd'hui avec un plan comme
un qui se retourne contre elle puisque
elle est très embêté très embêté elle
peut pas répondre oui elle peut pas
répondre donc elle ne répond pas et donc
ça fait ça fait une mise en scène sur
une mise en scène
que notre pays est rattaché
Bruni-Sarkozy ou pas
oui mais c'est quand même un problème
mais c'est quand même les gens vont
pouvoir vivre avec 1200 € par mois sur
Paris qui va régler ses problèmes là on
s'en branle
il résout pas
pour divertir
Thierry Mariani il y a plus de vous
qu'on a pas entendu là dessus est-ce que
ce gosse va diriger l'EHPAD
Mariani et maintenant je souhaite pour
qu'il soit heureux c'est pas un
événement mais j'allais dire ce qui
m'intéresse c'est ce qui va se passer
dans les prochains mois au niveau
politique
de la semaine avec les deux
[Musique]
en France il y a un vrai problème avec
immigration chaque année 200000 immigrés
s'installe en toute légalité chez nous
alors si nous voulons que la France de
la France
on a pas le choix il va falloir
accueillir au plus bas pour que la
France reste la France c'est-à-dire la
5e puissance économique au monde
[Musique]
5 % de ce qui arrive en France non pas
de formation ça fait donc de la main d'
œuvre pas cher qui accepte sale boulot
pas étonnant que Laurence Parisot la
patronne des patrons défendre elle aussi
les migrations
pareil pour la presse économique cette
semaine Les Echos le journal du
milliardaire Bernard Arnault a publié
une enquête démontrant les bienfaits de
l'immigration en mars c'est son
concurrent La Tribune qui publié
l'interview de deux économiste affirmant
l'économie française a besoin de 10
million d'immigrés d'ici 2040
malheureusement tous les ouvriers ne
doivent pas lire la presse économique
puisque selon le dernier sondage 36 %
d'entre eux ont l'intention de Beauté Le
Pen en 2012
voilà c'était les vidéos de Black Ops 2
mise en images de Julien grave voilà
vraiment la droite extrême parce que
d'après Christine Lagarde et Laurence
Parisot du Medef l'immigration et une
chance pour la France parce qu'il a
besoin de main d' œuvre pas cher c'est
pour ça qu'ils sont venus à l'époque
pour travailler dans les usines
française au moment des trentes
glorieuses et il y a une autre partie de
la droite donc vous faites partie qui
s'inquiète de l'arrivée de tous ces
immigrés en fait vous mettre d'accord je
te l'ai qu'est-ce qu'on dit on dit que
simplement les migrations choisi on doit
adapter le nombre en fonction de la
situation économique aujourd'hui
les immigrés en situation régulière sur
au chômage pour 24 % d'entre
c'est-à-dire 3 x + 3 fois plus que la
moyenne nationale pourquoi d'ailleurs
votre portable un peu dit parce qu'ils
sont sous forme et que dit Claude Guéant
Petit Nicolas Sarkozy simplement la
politique migratoire en voile adapter en
fonction des besoins du pays et donc
quand on est en période d'expansion bien
oui il faut plus d'immigrés quand on est
en période de récession il en faut un
peu moins je répète 3 plus de chômage
chez les immigrés en situation régulière
ça devrait quand même poser une question
on est toujours au cœur de cette
politique essuie-glace de diversion
alors comment on fait diversion a un an
de la présidentielle on dit que le
problème c'est qui a trop d'immigrés qui
a trop d'immigration comme si c'était le
problème central en l'occurrence c'est
ce que c'est une immigration seulement
de travail il y a des pubs qui se libère
de dictature et au même moment on dit on
va aller leur apporter la liberté avec
nos bombe avec nos missile en Libye on
veut pas c'est peuple on ne veux pas de
leurs étudiants on veut pas de leur
jeunesse ils vont au Québec ils vont
dans d'autres pays la France sous cette
présidence a décroché du monde avant la
France elle avait un rapport au monde et
elle disait quelque chose au monde elle
était pas un village gaulois barricader
tu rappelles quand même il a fallu que
le sage Robert Badinter rappels au
Premier ministre que dire français
d'origine musulmane c'est bizarre c'est
pas une origine la religion qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire en clair ça veut dire
quoi une époque on disait d'origine
juive voilà on commence à sélectionner
il faut les laisser aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui les personnes qui quitte la
Tunisie pour venir en France et puis pas
l'oppression politique mais ils viennent
peut-être le droit de dire on a eu votre
sol en priorité les réfugiés politiques
toujours fait et pour moi c'est toujours
le premier pays européens et l'Italie a
à peu près 10 miles de la France
en as quand même le droit de dire en
dehors des réfugiés politiques qui sont
menacés dans leur cher et bien on
choisit d'accueillir une immigration
économique dans ton définit le niveau
qu'est-ce que vous nous proposez vous le
proposez que désormais je connais
personne qui arrive
un peu humble je dis juste que quand on
a cautionner cette dictature dictature
fermer les yeux sur la privation de
liberté et bien dans ces cas-là on est
un peu généreux et on considère pas
qu'on envoyant quelques rafale ça suffit
pour aider les pubs qui veulent se
libérer si vous êtes d'accord qu'on a
besoin des immigrés pour travailler
dans les usines il faut payer les
retraites parce qu'on fait souvent les
immigrés il
est
aujourd'hui le boulot
du travail à ceux qui sont en respecter
les lois de la République
quand même
ça fait beaucoup
c'est
pour
ça
éplucher des sondages d'opinion et avec
la décision qui a été prise ils ont
élaborer une stratégie es un vrai choix
aujourd'hui politique qui est orienté la
campagne à droite tout et on va pouvoir
se récrier et plus on se réécrire à vous
savez et puis c'est trop content parce
qu'on sera qui va qui va je pense que
le peuple en profondeur il n'y a pas
demandé ça on entendait pas parlé du
Front National et des étrangers et des
immigrés dans les manifestations sur les
retraites quand le peuple se mobilise
sur les questions sociales et les
questions démocratique il se fait pas la
guerre au nom de l'origine vous avez
entièrement raison le programme est fixé
par Patrick Buisson c'est un idéologue
de l'extrême droite je le redis là le
problème n'est pas le Front national la
droite extrême est au pouvoir
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus une droite
républicaine il y a eu Victor Hugo et
Napoléon III y aura svp mail à Nicolas
Sarkozy
non mais
j'ai vécu le plus longtemps que vous
donc c'est ça c'est ça l'avantage d'un
énorme inconvénients mais c'est un tout
petit avantage et et malheureusement il
y a quelque chose là qui comment ça
ressemble à quelque chose qui ne sent
pas bon oui ce matin en allant visiter
l'appartement de mon enfance j'y avais
un mur pignon il y avait été il y a
55 ans ou presque 60 ans par des
Italiens et à l'époque on les appelait
les [ __ ] est déjà on les faisait chier
parce qu'ils étaient ritale et nous il y
avait un mec qui fait tout le temps que
j'appelais Gigi il adorait les gosses de
la rue des Martyrs et on le défends des
contre le retourne dans ton pays tout ça
tout ça c'est resté gravé j'ai pas envie
que ça recommence j'ai pas envie que les
Gigi d'aujourd'hui qui ont des gueules
d'arabe mais oui mais ils sont aussi
français j'ai pas envie j'ai pas envie
qu'on les emmerdes
ça sera le mot de la fin
très belle conclusion de Pierre Arditi
merci Anna merci d'avoir été avec nous
c'est un plaisir de vous avoir à très
bientôt j'espère nous on se retrouve
après la vision
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours en compagnie de
Pierre Arditi
Thierry Mariani
mais nous accueillons notre invité du
samedi 20h ce soir Olivia Chaumont
Bonsoir
alors Olivia jusqu'à 50 ans vous avez
été un homme marié sous le nom d'Olivier
vous diriger une grosse agence
d'architecture à Paris vous étiez membre
du Grand Orient de France mais à 50 ans
submergé par votre transidentité
jusqu'alors et tout fait j'ai fini par
céder à votre désir de devenir femme
raconte une autre histoire à 20h en
attendant j'accueille Stéphane Guillon
mais d'abord le zapping voilà c'était le
zapping à vous Stéphane pour la semaine
de Lyon
[Musique]
et on commence par la grande nouvelle de
la semaine Carla Bruni serai enceinte la
première dame aurait réalisé
l'échographie des trois mois alors c'est
encore trop tôt pour savoir s'il s'agit
d'un garçon ou d'une fille mais l'enfant
est bien du président le fœtus est
minuscule et bouge énormément
[Applaudissements]
déception revanche pour Nicolas Sarkozy
qui ne pourra pas prendre le nourrisson
dans ses bras sa naissance le personnel
soignant et formel le syndrome du bébé
secoué ça peut être très grave
Nicolas Sarkozy qui a été bercé tout
petit par son papa Pal Sarkozy tout à
fait on a encore les conséquences
Carla Bruni enceinte info ou intox
interroge VSD ils écrivent quand même
que Madame Sarkozy arborer un petit
ventre samedi dernier je souhaite à la
direction du journal que Carla soit
vraiment enceinte écrire que Madame
Sarkozy et ballonné ça peut leur coûter
très cher
[Applaudissements]
Éric Zemmour pourrait être le parrain du
futur nouveau-né ben oui comme Brice
Hortefeux condamné pour injures raciales
est le parrain de Jean Sarkozy ce serait
bien que des Moures condamné pour
provocation à la haine raciale sois pas
aussi la cohérence dans une famille
c'est important
les Japonais souhaite planter des pieds
de cannabis autour de la centrale de
Fukushima
le Racing capture la radioactivité les
Japonais faut pas qu'il fume avant de
proposer des idées la situation est bien
trop grave
[Applaudissements]
oui c'est que c'est drôle
crois aux forces de l'esprit je ressens
souvent le besoin d'être au contact de
la nature et proche des arbres pour
réfléchir c'est en lisant le conte
philosophique zadig et voltaire au pied
d'un arbre centenaire que Frédéric
Lefebvre a décidé qu'il fallait détecter
les comportement dangereux de la
maternelle
il faut surtout pas qu'il fume le
cannabis de Fukushima
il en a pas besoin c'est comme Obélix il
est tombé dedans petit
à Champigny en architecte a créé un
immeuble avec des maisons individuelles
perché sur le toit ça c'est une idée qui
l'a piqué au Japon ils font ça depuis
des semaines des maisons des bateaux des
bagnoles perché sur le toit
Pepsi-Cola arrive en Afghanistan a été
préférée à Coca-Cola ils ont fait des
tests en aveugle c'est la grande
spécialité
qui a gagné
[Applaudissements]
déclaration de Sophie Favier le Collaro
show m'empêcher d'être avocate et bah la
justice française peut remercier le
Collaro show
[Applaudissements]
le Front national a enfin vendu ses
anciens bureaux le paquebot a été
racheté par un propriétaire de maison de
retraite ça tombe bien Jean-Marie Le Pen
va pouvoir rester sur place si on
pouvait également réserver une chambre
pour Jean-Paul Guerlain ce serait bien
notre fils spécialisé dans les vieux
tenant des propos racistes pour les
chambres on prendrait des noms rigolos
la Zemmour Ménard la Claude Guéant la
Dieudonné de la gueule non
d'après un sondage du Parisien Nicolas
Hulot est la personnalité politique avec
qui les Français préféré passer l'été
les vacances avec Hulot quelle horreur
Dominique Strauss-Kahn et la quatrième
personnalité politique avec qui les
Français aimeraient passer les tu es là
tu dois te marrer des vacances avec DSK
tu bouffes tu fais la fête la lumière
est allumée dans toutes les pièces en
revanche faut tenir le coup c'est très
physique il faut pas être farouche du
matin au soir dans toutes les pièces le
jardin la piscine même si tu te laves
de Madagascar
[Musique]
il y a du soleil et des sky
jusque-là
sur Canal+. Fr
on passe maintenant à notre invité du
samedi 20h
[Musique]
Oliviero Bonsoir donc vous êtes né le 30
octobre 1950 à Meudon sous le nom
d'Olivier dans une famille de 5 enfants
père ingénieur dans la marine mère femme
au foyer vous dit génétiquement j'étais
un garçon j'avais des jouets de garçon
on met du quai comme un garçon mais moi
je me sentais attiré par le monde des
filles
c'est terrible c'est vraiment donner le
change
des petites copines ou dit j'étais
sûrement plus romantique que les autres
et ça plaisait vraiment
une femme mais c'est absolument
et
quoi
vous voulez devenir pilote de ligne mais
un problème d'oreille interne
et architecte et
dans les années 70
vous arranger de votre problème quoi là
vous êtes toujours effectivement un
garçon après 10 ans d'études vous
travaillez à Marseille et le temps vous
semble long parce que vous retrouver un
peu isolé seul face à vous-même et vos
pulsion identitaire redouble et c'est là
que vous découvrez l'existence de Bambi
et coccinelle qui étaient des artistes
transexuel à l'époque et vous vous dites
c'est possible je vais le faire quoi
comme
ça m'a fait comprendre que oui c'est
possible
que c'est où la rue
transexuel qui se prostituer de l'argent
qui était totalement dépressive
donc j'ai dit non ça c'est pas possible
tu peux vivre ma vie mais pas ce prix
toujours
en 1980 vous avez 31 ans pour monter à
Paris pour ouvrir une agence
d'architecture à votre compte rapidement
les premiers contrat non seulement elle
est rangé ça marche
comme les autres
pourquoi
c'est un engagement c'est un engagement
personnel j'avais toujours dit que je ne
me mettrai sans aucune bannière faisons
qu'un détendeur finalement c'était très
confortable de rester chez soi dans sa
politique et puis des circonstances
étaient les européennes et c'est une des
première année où le Front national
avait fait un score très élevé comme un
catalyseur dans ma décision je suis que
je
fasse quelque chose
ensuite vous marier
oui les années passent la pression monte
à l'intérieur de vous et un jour après
50 ans de comédie vous comprenez que tu
lui tu es quoi il faut que Olivier
devienne Olivia au risque de perdre tout
ce que j'avais construit en images
souvent d'une vague qui vient frapper
demain sur une dis et puis
donner pour des raisons tout à fait à
ce moment-là je me suis dit que ça te va
aller à votre feminité vous vous épiler
les sourcils de plus en plus
parce que
voilà
quoi
sur la transidentité et ce sont les deux
éléments de la vie la société pour
rencontre d'un côté la médecine
médical et l'autre côté plus tard on
verra le corps juridique on ne peut pas
vivre sa transidentité indépendamment de
la société comme l'homosexualité qu'on
peut vivre tout à fait
au bout de quelques mois
votre votre visage
j'irai heureusement que votre père n'est
pas là pour voir ça parce que ça aurait
été chaud ou non
oui je pense que
c'était un homme tolérant je pense qu'il
aurait finalement accepté la chance à
l'époque refuse de vous appeler Olivia
pendant un premier temps ça a été
difficile alors là votre couple vole en
éclats j'imagine que votre femme voyance
a
divorcé voilà
aussi de
votre carte d'identité
monter à devoir décliner son identité à
la poste demande la procuration de votre
mari la carte vitale pour un billet
d'avion une voiture enfant passe son
temps à décliner son identité donc on
est en permanence racheter dans la
masculinité voilà
décidé de changer de sexe alors le plus
sûr c'est la Thaïlande
voyage organisé voilà ça coûte 15000 €
all inclusive tout compris quoi on
arrive là-bas à l'aéroport et quelqu'un
qui vous attend à Bangkok et qui vous
amène dans une clinique quoi
la veille de l'opération plus peur de
l'opération que du changement de sexe en
fait
ça dure 6h c'est une opération très
dangereuse
évidemment la
construction d'un vagin
tout de suite parce que il faut faire
une demande c'est très compliqué et
c'est là que dans les critères qui sont
imposés pour changer d'identité on vous
oblige avoir eu l'opération
ça c'est quelque chose qu'il faut bien
comprendre que justement les personnes
dont je parlais tout à l'heure qui ne
désire pas être opéré on va les obliger
à être opéré et quand il s'agit d'une
femme qui devient un homme ou
l'opération est quasiment impossible la
nature on a copie pas comme ça alors là
on leur demande de stériliser
changer de prénom c'est vraiment
pratique pour
changer de prénom
alors
il faut rien dans tout ça c'est que sur
le plan sexuel vous retrouvez vos
préférences les femmes de Lévis rapport
avec des femmes tu dis on est lesbienne
il me dit je ne m'étais encore jamais
senti aussi femme vraiment ça s'est bien
passé
non ce sont un peu un peu idiote
il y a un truc aussi qui doit être
intéressant c'est comme vous étiez un
homme chef de votre agence
d'architecture quand vous disiez un truc
tout le monde obéit c'est est-ce que
c'est pareil quand on est une femme
ça c'est quelque chose qu'on peut pas
imaginer avant quand on est on sait
qu'on va arriver sur l'autre rive et on
sait pas ce qu'on va trouver là-bas on
imagine on met quand on arrive on sait
pas et j'ai découvert que c'était
peut-être une dent aujourd'hui et
maintenant quand on me demande ce que je
fais je dis je suis architecte
d'intérieur décorateur
alors est-ce que vous regrettez pas de
pas l'avoir fait plus tôt
possible pour moi dans les conditions
étaient les miennes en Vendée
aujourd'hui c'est diagnostic est
beaucoup plus tôt il faut savoir que des
parents peuvent être confronté à sa
16 17 ans 1 enfants une fille et un
garçon peuvent présenter ce désir d'être
dans l'autre jour ça peut être
accompagné et non plus comme avant ou en
chercher à guérir voulait absolument
nous nous
étions
une place dans la société car il faut
absolument
aujourd'hui ça n'existe pas
j'ai dit à mon formidable
je prépare les propos de Livia il y a un
calme et sérénité de lucidité très
bonnes auto-analyse juin
vous devez avoir beaucoup de charme
comme et vous avez fini comme femme je
vous dis
un tableau de mon père s'appelle la
péruvienne j'ai l'impression que ce
tableau qui m'accompagne depuis mon
enfance et depuis un quart d'heure
si vous
remercie
pour le président de
trop.
Merci
à tous
émission je voulais te parler des
émissions des gros cons pour les abonnés
à 20h50
la semaine prochaine
sur canal+
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu